hi there i don't know how well this is
going to work i'm standing a little
further away from my ipad trying to find
a place without too much wind hope the
wind doesn't destroy the sound here
i want to talk about languages the other
day i had six interviews in barcelona
i had
interviews here in hirona
talking about languages but when i had
my interviews in barcelona it was the
european day of languages
and that got me to thinking about
languages so of course i'm here in
catalonia
the language especially
perhaps perceived as a minority language
it's perhaps a minority language in
spain
but
in terms of europe it's actually
quite a widely spoken language there are
more catalan speakers than speakers of
finnish or or latvian or estonian or
lithuanian or
you know i mean croatia has only four
million people but of course serbo
croatia is a much larger language
well it turns out in catalonia
there are four official languages
there's spanish catalan
aranes which is a language spoken by a
very small number of people in a valley
close to the french border
very similar to
a dialect of a southern french language
which is also not widely spoken
and and it makes me realize like
unfortunately there was a tendency
in previous centuries to centralize like
in france they suppressed other
languages the the people in brittany
don't speak
there were a variety of southern french
languages that are no longer spoken uh
many of which were similar to
catalan is more similar to some of those
southern
and
of course it's not as if the people who
live in france or the world daily deals
this sense of loss that we don't have
those languages however
if we did have those languages if people
wanted to speak them if they spoke them
that doesn't mean that people in france
can't communicate with each other
because you can have
a national language and you can have a
regional language
i mean here in catalonia it's
extraordinary how people switch back and
forth between catalan and spanish but
catalan is sort of their identity as
catalan people
and
they are
from what i can gather tremendously
bilingual much like what i saw in
ukraine where people might even be more
comfortable speaking russian but they
recognize that ukrainian
is sort of a symbol of their national
identity
in canada
there's much talk about
in a way reviving or at least making
sure we maintain
indigenous languages
and i think the conditions are there to
do that and they've never been better
because
you know unfortunately what tends to
happen is if
say we're going to talk about
you know
maintaining or strengthening the
position of say cree in canada what
happens is people
want to find ways to access government
funding to write up great long grammars
of the cree language all of which is
quite unnecessary what's needed is to
get people who speak the language to
talk to each other and to transcribe
that so that we build up this corpus
of language
content in say cree
ranging perhaps from simple you know
mini stories like we have at link to
people talking about things that matter
to them and so you could go to a website
and find this enormous treasure trove of
people speaking that language then
people could learn that language because
you know
people obviously speakers of the
language but people it's sort of like
chicken and egg like we don't speak the
language because we don't hear it and
then we give up and then we speak
english and nothing prevents people in
canada from being fluent speakers of
english or french and participating
fully in all aspects of canadian life
and yet still be speakers of
cree let's say
so
i think
it's not an either or similarly
it's kind of i think unfortunate that
the world has
i mean it's useful to have english as an
international language but it means that
every time english speakers go anywhere
their basic assumption is wherever they
walk you know walk into a store or
something
the local people have to speak what is
to them a foreign language in order to
communicate with you that's not a
realistic expectation
if we had and i think again conditions
are are very favorable if we revived and
strengthened minority languages regional
languages
which spanish spanish certainly is
which arabic is
which
russian is which
indonesian is uh
i've left some out undoubtedly turkish
languages perhaps
strengthen these regional languages so
that when you travel in the world
you have a few other options besides
english
so
you know and and i think i don't think
one needs to have a sense of obligation
about learning or preserving these
languages it should be done in a way
that we do it because we want to do it
because it's fun it's fun to speak these
languages it's fun to learn languages
spoken by
relatively few people
catalan is not it's not that few it's
whatever it is five six million people
but i come here and i hear it and it's
very melodious and i like the sound of
it i'd like to learn it and we are gonna
have it at link and uh i don't know if
you're
you know in myanmar and uh
you get interested in the language
uh it's a c note it's related apparently
to tibetan and if you get into that
language then you might learn tibetan
and but then you have to have the
resources
and that's why i think the major sort of
emphasis in trying to
once again revive or to preserve or
strengthen these various languages be
the original or
even spoken by very few people is to
work together to develop sort of
corpuses
audio with text where these languages
can be accessed rather than
reinventing yet another grammar book
which is not going to help an awful lot
of people
so just my thought on on the european
languages i think it's great that there
are so many languages in europe it
doesn't prevent people from
communicating
um
i think the more language as i said the
other day the more languages you speak
the better you become
at speaking foreign languages learning
foreign languages
uh
and so i i'm hoping that the trend will
be
towards
multiplying the number of languages we
learn the number of languages that we
use
including very you know in languages
spoken by very few people right up to
languages spoken by a lot of people
anyway oh and i should say i'm at the
pga catalunya golf course because what
triggered my trip to europe
this time was the fact that my wife and
i are celebrating our 50th wedding
anniversary and she's very keen on golf
and she follows this british
golf pro on youtube called chris ryan
and he has a golf academy here and
that's what started it all and then we
built in the trip to croatia and visited
taragona and hirona so
go out there and learn languages and and
let's
create more diversity when it comes to
languages
that's what i have to say today bye for
now
[Music]
you